اكثر من 20 الف قتيل في زلزال تركيا
وسوريا فرق الانقاذ تسابق الزمن في البحث
عن الالاف من العالقين خبراء يتحدثون عن
تحرك تركيا ثلاثه امتار نحو الغرب هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد اربعه ايام على وقوع الزلزال المدمر
تخطت حصيله الضحايا في تركيا وسوريا حاجز
العشرين الف قتيل اضافه الى اصابه عشرات
الالاف بجروح مختلفه رئيس الجزيره
اردوغان اعلن عن مقتل
16,170 شخصا واصابه اكثر من 64 الفا اخرين
فيما بلغ عدد المباني المنهاره نحو 6400
مبنى اما في سوريا فتواصل قصيره الضحايا
الارتفاع مع انتشال المزيد من الجثث تحت
الانقاد لتصل الى
373 على الاقل في المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
النظام والمعارضه وفقا لما نشره المرصد
السوري
في اجواء من البرد الشديد ورغم التضاؤل
الامل يواصل عمال الانقاذ في تركيا وسوريا
جهودهم في البحث عن ناجين تحت انقاذ
الالاف من المباني المنهاره صحيفه اردودين
البريطانيه نشرت تقريرا قالت فيه ان الامل
في العفور على المزيد من الناجين بدا
يتضاءل ونقلت عن عمال الانقاذ في مدينه
قهرمان مرعش بقولهم انهم يشمون رائحه
الجثث خلال حفرهم وسط اكوام الانقاذ بعدما
دمر زلزال وهزاد ارتداديه العديد من
المباني في المدينه فيما قال احد
المتطوعين في عمليات الانقاذ للجاردين ان
معظم الاشخاص الذين عثروا عليهم تحت
الركام كانوا فقدوا ارواحهم
بعد اربعه ايام على وقوع الكارثه ومقتل
الالاف في سوريا دخلت اول قافله مساعدات
الى المناطق المتضرره في شمال سوريا وكاله
نقلت عن المسؤول الاعلامي في معبر باب
الهوى الحدودي بين تركيا وسوريا علوش قوله
ان اول قافله مساعدات من منظمه الامم
المتحده دخلت المعبر والتي كان من المتوقع
وصولها قبل وقوع الزلزال المدمر وذكرت
فرانستان القافله تتكون من ست شاحنات فقط
تضم بشكل اساسي مستلزمات خيم وادوات تنظيف
وكانت الامم المتحده دعت الى تنحيه
الخلافات السياسيه لضمان حصول السوريين
على الدعم العاجل بعد الزلزله للمدمر
في خبر اثار تفاعلا واسعا على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي كشف خبير ايطالي ان
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وما اعقبه
من هزات ارتداديه حركت البلاد ثلاثه امتار
باتجاه الغرب رئيس المعهد الوطني
الايطاليه للجيوب الفيزياء والبراكين
البروفيسور كارلو دوجليوني اوضح ان
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا مؤخرا حدث عند
نقطه التقاء صفائح شرق الاناضول مع
الصفيحه العربيه والافريقيه ولفظ دوبليون
ان التقديرات الحاليه تشير الى ازاحه
الصفيحه ثلاثه امتار لكن المعلومات
النهائيه سيتم الحصول عليها بعد الاطلاع
على بيانات القمر الصناعي
في خبرنا الاخير اعلنا مرصد ومعهد كنديري
لابحاث الزلازل في تركيا ان الزلزال الذي
وقع في قهرمان مرعش قد يتسبب في حدوث
تسونامي في البحر الابيض المتوسط وفي
حديثه مع شبكه سي ان ان قال مدير المرصد
هالوك اوزنر من بلاده تواجه اكبر اضرار
احدثها زلزال في هذه المنطقه منذ عام 1999
متحدثا عن توقعات باستمرار الهزات
الارتداديه لاشهر وربما تصل لعام واضاف ان
خطر الزلزال قد يتسبب في حدوث موجات
تسونامي في منطقه البحر المتوسط لافتا الى
ابلاغ اربعه عشر دوله بهذا
[موسيقى]